طبعا
نتنياهو هو استاذي الكريم اسرائيل دوله
هناك اجهزه امنيه هذه الاجهزه تعمل بحرفيه
وبمهنيه يعني ربما كان متوقع ان تطلق هذه
تطلق صواريخ من جهات داخل من الداخل
اللبناني طبعا بمباركه حزب الله انا لا
اتصور ولا يتصور احد في اسرائيل انه
بامكاني مجموعه مسلحه ان تطلق صواريخ على
ربما ليس بعلم الدوله اللبنانيه صحيح لان
الدوله غائبه تماما عن المشهد ولنتساءل
هنا اين هو رئيس الوزراء واين الحكومه
ولكن ليس بغياب ايران وايران في لبنان هو
حزب الله لا شك في ذلك هناك بنيه هرميه
وانا لا اتصور ان صاروخا واحدا من الممكن
ان يطلق من الاراضي اللبنانيه بدون علم
وبدون ان تكون هناك موافقه من القياده
الايرانيه عبر طبعا حزب الله بطبيعه الحال
انا اعتقد انه سوف يكون هناك ردا محدودا
حتى هذه اللحظه حيث توقف توقفت الضربات
ولكن في نهايه المطاف الحديث هنا عن جريمه
حرب لو لم تكن منظومه الق به الحديديه
لقتل مئات الاسرائيليين اسرائيل هذه
الضربات الهدف من هذه من هذه الضربات
الصاروخيه هو قتل قتل المدنيين قتل البشر
وبالتالي يجب ان تكون هناك انا اعتقد
الحكومه سوف ترد وترد بشكل حازم وقاطع
ولكن